I mean this must be huge though I mean
Taylor Swift she's voted by the most
powerful woman in the industry how big
is this that she's come out and written
this letter on her blog it's really big
and she's one of the few artists who has
the leverage to be able to do it
honestly to have that big of a megaphone
that big of a platform to stand on and
you know a lot of much smaller artists
are really applauding her her efforts
today you know that is why she said she
did it because it's a lot of the
independent artists that really haven't
been I guess might not be able to
benefit from some of this not being able
to get paid for those three months
during that trial period
how was everyone else in the industry
reacted to this as well I think you know
reaction has been kind of split to the
Apple music launch ever since it
basically was announced and I think that
there's a segment of the industry that
has a wait-and-see attitude you know
they have put a lot of faith in Apple
Apple is going to invest more money in
music this year than ever in its history
since the iPod and you know for an
industry that's struggling I think you
know no one's going to turn turn are no
one's going to turn down the help but on
the other side the independent labels
they're the ones who really they sort of
live month-to-month and for them to not
get paid for anything for three months
worth of streams I mean it could have
devastating effects on them on those
smaller companies so you know yeah
Taylor Swift she's part of the major
label machinery but she seems to be
taking one on the chin for the rest of
the you know the music community and
this is not the first time she's done
this I mean she pulled her album out of
Spotify just a couple months ago as well
but you know even the Spotify CEO
talking about just to apples emergence
and launching this streaming service and
it seems like they were just kind of
shrugging off saying he tweeted out oh
okay how much really of damage can Apple
really bring to the in terms of the
competitiveness of the streaming
industry well the big thing that Apple
as in its back pocket is 800 million
credit cards and you know what Apple
executives have told to me behind closed
doors is that they expect from this free
trial or as many as 50% of those people
to sign up for the subscription service
now Spotify boast 26 percent which is
also very impressive but just out the
gate Apple is looking to do twice what
Spotify zit on the other hand Spotify
has a huge huge head start
you know they've really like they've
planted their seeds in America and
internationally and they have a lot of
momentum you know going at this moment
so Apple in a weird sense and this
doesn't happen very often but they have
some catching up to do you know this
really does spark the conversation -
surely about whether we do need to see
some changes in the industry as well
there's a lot of these hardware and you
know companies are trying to shift all
to streaming do you see that more
artists going to be joining in along
Taylor Swift to really just boycott
these services all together you know I
don't think it's really too many artists
can't really have that decision power
and you know Taylor Swift like you said
she's one of the biggest artists in the
world so yeah she can pull her album
from from a catalog or from a streaming
service and it will make an impact but
most smaller bands who are signed to
small labels you know they depend on
those companies to get them on these
streaming services and honestly if
anyone's paying attention they would
know that between 2006 and between 2016
and 2026 is going to be the biggest
decade of growth for streaming music so
any band artist singer that's not on
that train it is in danger of missing
out